sam remy has done an interview regarding
multiverse of madness however he was
asked a question regarding the future of
spider-man 4 with tobey maguire the
question was tobin why spider-man is
back as part of the marvel multiverse
thanks to no way home so would you be
open to making some version of a
spider-man movie again after all this
time which sam remy responds with if
that was a great story that i think it
will be my love for the characters
hasn't diminished it would be the same
things that would stop me now that
stopped me then does toby want to do it
is there an emotional arc for him is
there a great conflict for this
character and is there a worthy villain
that fits into the theme of the piece
there's a lot of questions that would
have to be answered if those could be
answered then i would love to so there
we have it guys this is an official
update regarding the future of samurai
spider-man 4. now with the first
question does toby want to do it well i
believe this has already been answered
because toby maguire has been asked
previously in interviews for no way home
and for memory i believe he has answered
that he would be certainly down for a
film like this now i remember there were
rumors in the past of the spider-man 4
already being in production but
according to this interview that was
done with sam romy this this pretty much
confirms that those rumors are false in
this if he's hiding something which i
don't think he is but nevertheless this
is actually still very exciting news
because now we know that sam remy and
toby maguire are both down for fourth
spider-man film so essentially it's down
to marvel now and also for samurai's
questions to be answered it looks like
they will need a really good script for
this film for sam romy to be interested
in directing it but either way i think
the future for marvel was looking bright
but first thing is first we have doctor
strange and a multiverse of madness to
look forward to sam mermaid is back and
i'm really excited to see what he has in
store for us for this film with that out
of the way what do you guys think of
this news do you think we'll see a
spider-man 4 let me know in the comment
section below and if you did enjoy the
video please like and subscribe thanks
for watching guys